well speaking of fun on the strip you
can pretend to have your own vegas
residency at the one and only
karaoke experience on the strip rocky is
live at the grand canal shops at the
palazzo where you can make
all your karaoke dreams come true and do
it safely
yeah okay so we're not inside of a
spaceship
we are at the palazzo the venetian for
kamu ultra karaoke you guys this place
is so cool i don't know if you
frequented
um karaoke bars you know before the
pandemic but
this is top notch come on evan let's go
show them
the way so this is just the hallway but
then you enter into the vip experience
if you are
mercedes do you hear that that's what a
man buy salt and pepper because that's
her favorite
her favorite karaoke song to do and i
wanted to intro what a man because i
want to intro
evan as a water man because you
are the reason the protocols are in are
in place you're the reason why karaoke
is back in vegas so let's have a seat
all right
let's let's talk what are the protocols
how do we do this safely
okay well first of all when you walk in
the room you saw a uvc door that you
walked through yes
and then we escort the guests you come
in and this is one of the largest vip
rooms
yes um enough social distancing plenty
so there are
40 private rooms in this entire
establishment it's the largest in the
entire country and we have six vip rooms
here and the largest one here
so when you walk in the room obviously
we have foot placement stickers to
monitor social distances okay uh on your
microphones you have uh microphone
covers that are applied and disposable
oh wow wait this part is disposable
no no this part right here
supposed to be on the mic but we're
going to clean these up and because
they're private rooms the new protocols
allow us to
you have to wear a mess if you're not
eating drinking or singing okay
if you are then you're not required to
wear masks in private rooms got you and
you mentioned eating and drinking and i
want to show you guys
the setup that simbar vip host set up
for us look at that spread okay but this
is just
the fruit platter i want to bring up the
video of their menu on their website
because it is elaborate you guys are
luxurious here
what's on the menu oh you like lobster
sandwiches
uh there is um there's all types of oh
sorry there are different types of
korean dishes chopped cheese another one
and soon to come in may is going to be
sushi
oh karaoke and sushi i'm sold i'm sold
you got to come here after may 1st oh my
god i'm so excited okay so last but not
least here
i want to turn off simba can you show us
this is the technology obviously this is
not a book this is a computer
display let's turn on simply the best by
tina turner because that's jc's
favorite karaoke karaoke song absolutely
let's do it so look how this works you
guys
have a regular i can start it i don't
need no karaoke machine i can just go
i can just go sign me up
it looks so cool it looks awesome and
mercedes are gonna have sushi and
karaoke
i'm ready to go basically they're
setting it up for us and we're going to
go there later thank you ross
we're going to check back in with you
during the 4 pm
newscast